SINCE DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN
QUARANTINING TWO YEARS.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA WHAT'S GOING
ON.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED WHEN YOU
STAY INSIDE AFRAID OF CROWD AND
CHECK TWITTER ALL DAY.
IT TOOK A POLLSTER TO BREAK THE
NEWS TO THEM.
THAT EVERYBODY HATES THEIR WOKE
NONSENSE.
EVEN DEMOCRAT VOTERS.
AND THEY ARE ABOUT TO GET
ANNIHILATED IN NOVEMBER.
SO NOW THE PARTY IS PANICKING.
JOE BIDEN ISN'T RESPECTED, BRAND
NEW POLLING SHOWS HIM AT 37%
APPROVAL BIDEN DIDN'T SHUT DOWN
THE VIRUS EVERYBODY GOT IT.
PRESIDENT ISN'T DOING ANYTHING
ABOUT IT TWO OBAMA OFFICIALS ARE
NOW TELLING BIDEN YOU BETTER GET
IT TOGETHER.
AND THE "NEW YORK TIMES" ARTICLE
FORMER OBAMA GUY, STEVE RATTNER
SAYS BIDEN'S EXCUSE FOR
INFLATION IS DISHONEST AND DAVID
AXELROD SAYS IT'S TIME FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO GROW UP AND BE A
LITTLE MORE HUMBLE.
BUT THE DESTRUCTION OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY STRETCHES FAR
BEYOND JOE BIDEN.
AND FOR ONCE, MSNBC GETS
SOMETHING RIGHT.
>> THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO STEP
AWAY FROM THE SUPER WOKENESS.
YOU HAVE THREE SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS THAT WERE VOTED OUT BY
70% BECAUSE THEY ARE FOCUSING ON
THINGS LIKE CHANGING THE NAMES
OF SCHOOLS.
ABRAHAM LINCOLN ON A SCHOOL.
GEORGE WASHINGTON ON A SCHOOL.
THIS IS NOT WHAT VOTERS CARE
ABOUT.
YOU NEED TO STEP AWAY FROM SUPER
WOKENESS.
>> Jesse: FASTEST WAY TO STOP A
CULTURE WAR IS LOSE IT THAT'S
WHAT DEMOCRATS SHOULD DO.
SURRENDER, BLACK THE BLUE, SCRAP
CRT AND START ACTING NORMAL
AROUND CHILDREN AGAIN.
STILL HANDS ON DECK ON THE
MEDIA.
THEY SEE THE LANDSLIDE COMING.
EVEN THE ASSOCIATED PRESS SAYS
THE BRAND IS SO TOXIC.
DEMS HERE EXTENSION IN RURAL
U.S.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS LOSING
VOTERS FASTER THAN CNN IS LOSING
VIEWERS.
I KNOW, THAT FAST.
SO APPARENTLY IT'S TIME FOR A
COSTUME CHANGE.
DEMOCRATS ARE RUNNING AS
REPUBLICAN THAT'S HOW BAD THAT
THIS IS THEY DON'T CARE THEY
WANT TO HOLD ON THAT BADLY.
SUDDENLY DEMOCRATS WANT TO
REOPEN SCHOOLS AND GET RID OF
MASKS AND NANCY PELOSI IS THE
LAW AND ORDER CANDIDATE.
>> THERE ARE SOME ISSUES THAT WE
ASK POLICE TO DO.
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES, OR
POLICING IN SCHOOLS AND ALL THE
REST THAT PERHAPS WE CAN SHUFFLE
SOME OF THAT MONEY AROUND.
>> CORI BUSH, CONGRESSWOMAN FROM
MISSOURI IS SAYING IT'S TIME TO
DEFUND THE POLICE.
SHE IS STICKING BY THAT.
>> WITH ALL THE RESPECT IN THE
WORLD FOR CORI BUSH, THAT IS NOT
THE POSITION OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
COMMUNITY SAFETY, TO PROTECT AND
DEFEND IN EVERY WAY IS OUR OATH
OF OFFICE.
DEFUND THE POLICE IS DEAD.
IS.
>> Jesse: DEFUND THE POLICE IS
DEAD BECAUSE IT KILLED PEOPLE.
AND THOSE BODY BAGS LIE AT THE
DOORSTEP OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
IT'S OBVIOUS THE DEMOCRATS ARE
FAILING THE EXAM.
SO THEY'RE JUST CHEATING AND
STEALING THE ANSWER FROM
REPUBLICANS.
THAT'S SIMPLE.
THE LEFT IS EVEN CALLING FOR TAX
CUTS.
AT THIS POINT, DEMOCRATS MIGHT
WANT TO FINISH THE WALL.
WE CAN ONLY DREAM.
BUT THE ENTIRE PARTY ISN'T ON
BOARD WITH THIS PIVOT.
SOME DIDN'T GET THE MEMO.
FOR EXAMPLE, SOME ARE BLAMING
THE WACKY SAN FRANCISCO SCHOOL
BOARD RECALL ON WHITE SUPREMACY
CALLING FREEDOM A CODE WORD FOR
RACIST.
YEAH.
FREEDOM IS RACIST.
WHICH MEANS SLAVERY ISN'T
RACIST?
IT'S ALL VERY CONFUSING.
AND AOC CONTINUES TO AOC FOUGHT
TOOTH AND NAIL FOR THE PEOPLE
RELIEF PACKAGES.
STIMULUS CHECKS WE HAVE ACTUALLY
HELPED HUGE AMOUNTS OF
UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES GET
FEDERAL RELIEF THAT MANY OTHERS
WERE TRYING TO LOCK THEM OUT OF.
WELFARE FOR ILLEGALS I THINK I
KNOW WHAT THE MEMO SAID ABOUT
THAT.
THE QUESTION IS WILL THE PARTY
BE ABLE TO PULL OFF THIS COSTUME
CHANGE IN TIME FOR THE MIDTERMS
OR WILL THE LOUD MOUTHS DOLLARS
ON THE LEFT RUIN IT AND GET THE
PARTY STUCK IN AWOKE QUAGMIRE
JOINING ME NOW TO RESPOND VICTOR
DAVIS HANSON SENIOR FELLOW AT
THE HOOVER INSTITUTION.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY COULD BE
EXTINCT LIKE THE DINOSAURS
POTENTIALLY VDH, I MEAN, IS THIS
EVEN POSSIBLE?
>> WHERE WELL, THEY ARE AT THE
END OF THE HALLWAY AND THREE
DOORS OUT, JESSE.
YOU OUTLINED IT.
THEY HAVE A COGNITIVELY IMPAIRED
PRESIDENT WHO IS OBNOXIOUS AND
MEAN-SPIRITED AND HAVE ISSUES
THAT ARE PULLING LEFT IN HIS
37%.
SO OPTION ONE WAS AS YOU SAY,
THEY CAN DOUBLE DOWN.
THEY CAN SAY, YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE WOULD RATHER BE WRONG WITH
MARXISM AND SOCIALISM THAN RIGHT
WITH MODERATION GLORIOUS
REVOLUTIONARIES.
WE ARE GOING TO DOUBLE DOWN AND
GO FOR BROKE.
AND THEN THEY CAN SAY, YOU KNOW
WHAT?
THERE IS A DOOR B.
WE CAN GET DIRTY AND MEAN.
WE CAN GET THE ZUCKERBERGS AND
SILICON VALLEY SPEND ANOTHER
$114 MILLION TARGET PRECINCTS.
GET JANUARY 6TH BACK UP.
WE CAN GO AFTER DONALD TRUMP.
WE CAN GET ALL THIS MONEY WE CAN
FILE LAWSUITS.
THEY CAN DO THE TACTICS AND THE
METHODOLOGY ROUTE OR DO AS YOU
SAY.
DO THE DICK MORRIS 1995, '96
REMAKE OF BILL CLINTON AND
SUDDENLY REWILL HEAR ABOUT NIGHT
BASKETBALL AND SCHOOL UNIFORMS.
100,000 POLICE OFFICERS.
BUT THE PROBLEM WITH THE THIRD
IS THAT THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT
DEMOCRATS.
THEY'RE REVOLUTIONARIES.
AND WHAT THE RATIONAL LOGICAL
ANSWER IS SITTING THERE FOR
EVERYBODY TO SEE DOESN'T MEAN
THEY ARE GOING TO TAKE IT THEY
ARE EMOTIONAL.
AND THEY WOULD RATHER, AGAIN,
THEY WOULD RATHER BE WRONG AND
PURE THAN RIGHT AND MODERATE.
AND SO I DON'T THINK -- I DON'T
THINK THEY ARE GOING TO DO IT
AND THEY HAVE ANOTHER PROBLEM
WITH BEING MODERATE.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY TODAY ISN'T
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IN THE
90'S.
IT'S A POPULIST NATIONALIST
PARTY THAT IS APPEALING TO THE
MIDDLE CLASS MORE THAN THE VERY
WEALTHY, THE DEMOCRATS ARE THE
VERY WEALTHY AND THE VERY POOR.
THIS PARTY IS STARTING TO
TRANSCEND RACE AND REPLACE IT
WITH CLASS, MIDDLE CLASS
CONCERNS.
THEY DON'T HAVE A LOCK HOLD ON
HISPANICS OR AFRICAN-AMERICAN
MALES OR ASIANS AS THEY USED TO.
I THINK THEY HAVE A PROBLEM.
SO I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO
SELECT DOOR A AND GO DOWN TO
GLORIOUS DEFEAT AS
REVOLUTIONARIES.
>> Jesse: OKAY.
SO YOU ARE SAYING THEY ARE GOING
TO GO FOR BROKE.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BUY THEIR
WAY OUT.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO LIE THEIR
THEY ARE GOING TO GO WOKE.
GOING FOR BROKE.
>> YEAH.
>> DO YOU SEE THE RACE CARD
PLAYING A FACTOR IN THE MIDTERM
ELECTIONS?
BECAUSE THAT'S BEEN SO
EFFECTIVE.
THE GENDER CARD, THE RACE CARD.
I MEAN THAT IS THEIR BREAD AND
BUTTER.
WITH INFLATION AND GAS PRICES
AND CRIME AFFECTING BROAD
SWATHES OF THE POPULATION, RICH,
POOR, YOU KNOW, BLACK, WHITE,
EVERYBODY, IS THAT GOING TO
PLAY?
>>
>> I DON'T KNOW IF IT'S GOING TO
PLAY.
I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO LOSE
WHATEVER OF THE THREE
ALTERNATIVES THEY TAKE.
BUT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THEY WON'T
TAKE THE RADICAL ONE.
I THINK THEY WOULD RATHER LOSE
AND BE PURE.
SO THEY ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT
RACISM, TRANSGENDERISM.
SEXISM.
INEQUALITY, DIVERSITY -- ALL THE
WAY DOWN.
AND IF THEY LOSE, THEY ARE GOING
TO SAY, DO YOU KNOW WHAT?
WE HAD A GLORIOUS TWO YEARS OF A
AGGRESSIVE LEFT WING CONGRESS.
AND, YOU KNOW, THAT'S WHAT NEVER
GOING TO DO.
THEY ARE NOT RATIONALE PEOPLE.
>> Jesse: SELFISH PART OF ME
WANTS THEM TO TAKE DOOR A A.
KNOW THEY WILL GO DOWN IN
FLAMES.
IT'S NOT THE PATRIOTIC THING TO
THINK.
MAYBE I'M JUST, YOU KNOW, MAYBE
I'M JUST A SHALLOW PERSON.
ALL RIGHT.
VDH, THANK YOU AS ALWAYS F